I want to give you a quick update in
Brazil there was of course the
presidential election there in October
it was highly contested the Supreme
Court seems to be the repository of a
lot of power in Brazil maybe too much a
Supreme Court Justice called Alexandria
De mores as jail protesters censored
social media and the new government is
planning to ban something called fake
news this is all of concern to Glenn
Greenwald who is a journalist based in
that country he joins us tonight for an
update from Brazil Glenn how would you
thank you for coming how would you
assess what's going on there it's hard
to know from here
I think it's an extension of a lot of
trends that have been going around the
world and including the United States
which is the government View and the
internet as this extremely alarming
development because it gives power into
the hands of people to communicate with
one another to judge for themselves what
to believe and governments are looking
for ways increasingly to control that
and to prevent individuals from speaking
freely on it and Brazil has become like
this extreme manifestation of where this
is leading where I would really call it
judicial tyranny this one judge has the
ability to order people banned and
censored by telling social media
companies that unless they comply within
two hours they will start to experience
very significant fines he gives no
reason no evidence no notice to the
people who are being censored let alone
a fair trial of any kind it's just a
secret decree issued with no reasoning
and then these cut these people have to
be silenced including politicians who
got more votes than anyone from the
Brazilian people to represent them in
Congress I think this is where a lot of
countries are headed
so you are hardly have hardly been a
cheerleader for bolsonaro who who lost
or is no longer president anyway but
you've been attacked really strongly for
pointing out that you know you have to
have civil liberties in a functioning
country are you worried about your
safety there for saying that
you know it's interesting I mean my
under the bolsonaro government there
were prosecutors who tried to imprison
me for reporting that I did during those
years but I have to say that in all my
time as a journalist there was never a
moment where I thought to myself should
I really criticize this political
official is it really worth the risk
until I started in the past few months
criticizing this particular judge it was
the really the first time in the back of
my mind I thought maybe it's not worth
criticizing him because of the power
that he wields and the way that he's
proved he'll use it and that is a sign
that you live in a repressive climate
when you start being scared of even
criticizing a government official
well that's exactly right and Godspeed I
hope you'll keep us updated on what
happens to you Glenn Greenwald from
Brazil thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight